- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan academy.
My Social Security Number is 857,
- 32
- 5567.
No, it's not.
I wouldn't tell you my Social
Security Number like that.
And that's because
it is personally identifiable
information, or PII.
And there's a reason why
you want to keep that
to yourself, or at least
limit who has access to PII.
Because if someone has access,
they can expose your privacy,
tell the world where you
live, they could track you
and they could tell the
world what you've been up to,
maybe when you should be working
what websites you're visiting,
or, even worse, potentially,
they could steal your identity,
take money out of your bank account,
take a credit card in your name,
do some other form of identity theft
that could be embarrassing,
or super costly.
So, if you have some type of a service,
either online or otherwise,
that's asking for something
like your Social Security Number,
or your birthday, which might
be a little bit more indirect,
or your email address,
or your phone number,
you might ask why.
Sometimes there's a legitimate reason
why they need to know these things
but many times, I'd argue
even most of the time,
there might not be a legitimate reason.
And so you need to ask yourself, well
what are they going to do with it?
And if you don't feel comfortable
giving that information,
ask yourself, do you
really need that service?
So think seriously about your PII.
Unfortunately, bad actors
on the Internet are coming
up with new ways of
leveraging both direct PII,
personally identifiable information
like Social Security Numbers,
even biometrics, even your name,
and indirect measures, or
indirect pieces of PII,
like your birthday, or your
address, or your email address,
or your phone number,
that can be put together
to do shady things with your identity.
So be very careful.